little virtual soldiers to camp
and teaches them how to fight.
This is a follow up work to an absolutely
amazing paper called ASE. This is a previous
work with little AI soldiers that trained
for 10 years. 10 years? How? 10 years of
their in-game world that is, which is
fortunately when using a fast machine,
is only 10 days in our time. And they learned
a great deal. They went from a bunch of sorry
little recruits to battle-ready soldiers.
Except this chap. This chap goes like “Sir,
I’ve been training for two years, I’ve had
enough! And now, I shall leave… in style.”
In this new work, these little soldiers trained
for 5 billion training steps on a single graphics
card. It’s not a cheap one, but still, a single
graphics card. So, what do we get for these 5
billion training steps? Can this new one do
anything better than the previous one? Well,
first, it can learn from unlabeled motion
capture data. What is that? Well, a bunch
of dots moving that represents movements
of real humans that have been recorded.
Step number one. Basic training. Here, the
moving dots go in, and a neural network is
asked to create motions that are similar to it.
So, are we done? Well, not quite. You see,
we wish to use this in video games, and this is
not controllable yet. Imagine a video game where
you press a button on the controller, and nothing
happens. So now comes step number two. Precision
training! Here, it now needs to perform the
movements, but also listen to our controls,
especially when we use the stick to steer it
in different directions. And step number three,
here we not only give it directions, but intuitive
commands as well, such as striking or running.
So, all that is great, but what can it
really do now? Well, let’s see together.
For instance, it can interpolate between two
movement types. This means that it works like a
gymnast who has perfected a difficult routine. It
can't jump straight from one move to another. It
needs to transition smoothly to maintain balance
and perform the routine successfully. Thus,
it first starts running, and then, look, it
gradually dreams up a smooth transition from
sprinting to crouching. That is a really
nice and believable transition. Love it.
And now comes the best part. Hold
on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because now you’ll see how it can do these
types of transitions on-demand. That means,
as a reaction to our button
mashing on the controller. So good!
However, not even this technique is
perfect. It still has some issues to
be worked out. For instance, check this out. Now,
little AI, move towards the target.
Attack, great and now, celebrate!
Whoa! Careful! Moments like this show that this
work is still experimental. I don’t think you
will see this in a new game tomorrow, but this
is what research is about. Taking something
highly unstructured and using learning-based
techniques to create something useful from it.
Now, wait a second, in the intro, I also said
that this is a follow up to the ASE paper. So
how does it compare to that one? Oh my. Are you
seeing what I am seeing? Because I am seeing two
excellent news here. Now, I hear you asking,
okay Doctor, what are the excellent news here?
Well, one, let’s start with the most obvious
one - the controllability of the simulation has
improved leaps and bounds. That is incredible.
And second, what is even more incredible,
this controllability did not come at the expense
of the diversity of the movesets. That is perhaps
the best part of the paper - you see, this is in
a class of neural network-based based techniques
that often suffers from a phenomenon called
mode collapse. What is mode collapse? Well,
imagine asking a gymnast to perform incredible
acrobatics, and this gymnast can do a variety
of things, but unfortunately, just keeps doing
the same thing over and over again. Cartwheels
all day every day. Imagine looking at
an olympic gold-medal athlete who just
keeps doing cartwheels. And, it is not
the case here. This is an athlete that
can do everything. I absolutely love
this. Bravo! What a time to be alive!
And finally, some fantastic news for the end -
the source code of this project is available.
I would like to send a big thank you to
the scientists on this project making it
available for all of us, free of charge.
And for now, let the experiments begin!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!